[Music]
we greens like sweeney to the
nadine family month of march where speed bumps
or the boulou quid of may 1st her
knowledge yade gave this
circular notion she is strong
go permacon because there is
biodiversity c  that is to say that there are
several species which are mixed
together which allow you to
reinforce the production without chemical products
so it is the strength of the mixture of
species which makes it possible to install
permaculture
[Music]
to think of the great  wall g
but with permanent actions itil
and consecutive open so despite its
almost 100 feet of papaya
so if you have medicinal plants
in the foreground the
three plans there are dedicated to vegetables
a variety of vegetables
papayas lemons lemon trees sites  rice
the cashew trees the natives the fertile
lands heroes make the American ba-ba and
its sheets which are bigger so in the
end we got here